alright guys it's your boy psych out
here with a main man Donald Trump and
we're doing a little quest called pull
the plug and we are currently about to
start the quest word thicket excavations
which is to the right of red rocket shop
and a little northeast of museum of
freedom so that's no that's okay hi
looking to earn some cash yes yes yeah I
said I could give me some other probably
how I was gonna give you something
anyway Marmonte I'm up for it not gonna
make this easy alright Marv Monica's
pump fake just had to push didn't what
do you need help with the pump isn't in
top shape but should at least star must
be some the leaks will be underwater I
can't let stand us let's do this now my
name is psychobabble so don't worry
don't worry i look like it's like oh
there's a bubble hey bubble there I'm
just trying to find out this three right
one toe and Elmo says 30 before I get
[ __ ] irradiated and I put on hazmat
suit shut
ok ok here's another bubbling brook
where's the lake though all right where
is the lake I [ __ ] him I said I bet I
[ __ ] missed it ok ok ok 23 need some
[ __ ] air there we go baby there we go
I on dando standing gundog ending on the
one hand and all I animate psycho yeah
[ __ ] psycho I'd have to get out of
this place I don't know how to [ __ ]
outta her hairy guy I get hazed ass I
don't drink this [ __ ] I [ __ ] in this
water trying fetches drain hmm hey there
that's a ticket you do the honors hit
that switch on the end of the pond yet
switch at the end of the pump what a
[ __ ] is at don't even have this thing
connected that right here
all right let's say it baby let's say it
was a big [ __ ] place Jerian of the
water great i gotta [ __ ] this batch up
you know I just gotta [ __ ] this matchup
was it where is it I go for its legs cuz
i hate likes at it what if i redirect
Meyer loves I guess I shouldn't be
surprised that started
I still got some tape
be too hard now though thanks for
pitching in
there's a little something before you
I've got 50 okay pull the plug but the
cool thing is I'm actually going to
quickly go and lay our weight in one of
these um Ed's and you can see what it
looks like in a day or so wait which one
is it one of these has a cacao shell one
sec I think it's this one hello send you
are ok ok its weight that's wait and see
what happens yeah just way too [ __ ]
our [ __ ] happens just kidding there we
get away longer 24 hours okay baby okay
oh I love water oh baby baby Jesus [ __ ]
[ __ ] high tide it's so scary that's
when I guys come out
ok yeah well I don't know what's [ __ ]
Raiders here now ya know it really goes